we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail about someone who just seems
to be really confused i don't know what
this caller is talking about take a
listen i know when you call her i'm
calling from California some homeless
guys I had nothing to do but watch
YouTube you quickly become one of my
favorite but I'm a disappointed for what
I just saw about Penn Jillette confirms
Trump's wildly racist comments sounded
like you just set up the idea of
protecting your own show but give me the
impression if the trunk tapes come up
you're also not going to talk about it I
don't know what I have ever said to
suggest that if the Trump tapes are
released I'm not going to talk about
them and I don't think there is anything
people could could even point to that
suggests I would ignore that of course
we would cover that no I mean and by the
way yeah are they talking about the P
tapes or tapes of him directing Michael
Cohen to pay off I don't even know what
looks he's talking about but I wouldn't
I would talk about any relevant tapes
that come out I feel like it would be
like the Omarosa n-word tapes because my
sense on this the N word maybe you said
that it would just be a distraction from
all the stuff that's going on in the
Trump White House okay we would still
talk about it even if it is a
distraction now major news it would be
major news it would be a distraction
insofar as it doesn't seem Trump's
voters would care if he was throwing
around the n-word but no I would I would
not suppress that I would talk about it
on the program we have a great bonus
show for you today we'll talk about
Elizabeth Warren we will talk about
Mexico a city that has legalized public
sex we will also talk about Trump saying
de Blasio Bill de Blasio New York City
Mayor has no imagination after they use
similar slogans Trump criticizing others
for lack of creativity is an interesting
one all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get access as a
member or as a patron at join pakman.com
or patreon.com slash david pakman show